[Music]
what's up what's up what's up what's up
what's up welcome back to the edge with
your boy Michael pars live and your
Bleacher Report app as always drop any
questions and comments in the chat and
not responding during the show I know a
lot of you were probably worried about
my health but I'm back baby I am
back the fever is gone the chills is
gone the aches is gone everything's gone
the chest pain is gone there was a lot
of musinex there was a lot of everything
vitamin C packs IVs but guess what I'm
back I'm feeling better there is still a
little cough so I going say this
sickness will last about 3 to five days
there it go if you're lucky but
hopefully you guys do not get it you do
not want this a couple other my
teammates have got it listen stay away
from this right but simple stay healthy
wash your hands there's a lot of germs
out there let's get clean guys but
anyway let's get straight into the Joe
Jerry Jones was joking after the game um
he had screamed us out and and I wanted
to had laugh but every time I laughed I
would cough so I feel like I'm about to
cough right now and uh it was it was
like before the game um Jerry had came
up to me he was
like um I know you're not feeling well
and um you know Jerry only talks to you
at certain times in your life right
Jerry um if he likes you he'll always
shake your hand so um anytime I see
Jerry he'll shake my hand and smile so I
always say that's a good sign but um
he's not a man that'll give you a lot of
words he man he's a man that gives you a
lot of stories so anytime he talks about
the to the team or talks about anything
he brings up a past story um and when I
first met Jerry he was talking me about
uh he was like I know you're not feeling
well but I want to tell you about my
story um about this time I was in
Arkansas when cuz if you don't know
Jerry Jones obviously went to Arkansas
and he played football and uh he was
like I had to play a game and my my
appendix need to be taken out and it was
just killing me I barely could walk I
barely could walk and I was feeling it
the whole time and uh you know I was the
backup so if anyone went down I had to
go out there and I just didn't want to
lose my job and he said the first play
of the game that sucker got hurt and I
started chuckling so I said I guess you
play said yep I went out there and I had
my best game so I need you to go have
one of those and I was said you got it
boss and um you know that's just Jerry
um and he you know's he's just he's a
funny guy I would say um so that was it
um I was I was sick as hell at the day
of the game I was over 100 fever that
whole day I had a fever I think I woke
up to the fever of 100 to two and a half
and it was just it was just mind
blockling um I played multiple game sick
before I don't think sickness is a
really excuse not to play I Believe
something has to be broken something has
to be torn uh for me not to play
um anything else I feel like you can
deal with they always say there's a
difference between injured and hurt and
I just think sickness has just been a
part of injury you know you hurting your
body hurts a little bit but it is what
it is but I'm feeling great now that's
all that matters uh let's move on uh I
know y everyone's talking about ER Ferg
ER Ferguson um and he told uh he told a
fan that he would jump over an eagle and
uh that's Ferg I mean I mean if first of
all I want everyone to go vote for Jake
Ferguson I think he's having a great
year I think he should be a pro bowl
tight end um the way he's K and step up
this year is unbelievable for so go vote
Jay Ferguson right now uh cuz he's an
absolute dog absolute dog and uh he
doesn't say a lot but he talks a lot of
trash and I knew Jake would be a problem
cuz we had a little altercation in Camp
and um he never heard of me so I don't
want y'all to think that or anything
like that but uh we had gotten to it and
he kind of pushed me out the play I was
like oh that's how you want to do things
around here and you know he kind of like
oh yeah like bring it like and you know
that confidence that that that kind of
ego that he had to him I was like this
guy he's going to be a fighter um and
he's going to be a guy that he's going
to bring he's going to bring some energy
to this
offense um the vibe in the locker room
was pretty high I was obviously pretty
low I was pretty like just get me out of
here I need to go home and rest um but
we're number one in the NFC East we have
Bills Dolphins lines and commanders
remaining and uh it's going to be
intense I think this was just part of
the three-headed dragon cuz now we have
Bills Dolphins and lions and I think
there might be extra Dragon because we
we obviously cut off that Dragon but we
got a three-headed dragon coming up here
to good here the bills are a monster the
Dolphins are a monster the lions are the
monster and we also got a PR finish
really well finish really really well
and it's great because all these teams
are playoff caliber teams um and that's
always exciting because you get to see
these guys firsthand and uh it it's
super exciting uh getting them early
jump on them especially dolphins and
bills I think the bills can make a great
playoff push especially at the rate have
them beating Kansas City last week and
we'll get into that a little bit later
but uh this is a great team and I don't
think they should be slept on they
barely lost to the Eagles I mean a lot
of the games they lost were very close
games didn't roll their way so we should
not overlook this team after the Eagles
game Dak Prescott became the MVP
favorite he's now over 3500 yards 28
touchdowns and six
interceptions he's playing at a very
elite level outside of what outside of
stats what makes Dak a MVP candidate I
would say outside of stats Dak is a very
good person and I think he's a person
that makes everyone around him better I
mean I don't think he's just an MVP on
game day his whole process leading
up to the games is MVP caliber what he
puts into the game is second to none uh
always the first one in the building um
always the last one leaving the building
watching film you know even when I get
there a little early I see his car right
there next to the coach's car you know
Dak and then his energy at practice uh
making sure people running the routes
right uh putting energy out never having
a bad day uh you never know something's
going on with Dak because his mentality
and what he brings to the game so I
there's no doubt why when people ask me
in week nine why I thought Dak was going
to be an MVP candidate I've seen the
work I seen what he's putting in and
it's it's so exciting I wish you guys
could witness it and the gear he's
putting together um we're looking we're
going to be looking at one of the
richest men in America for sure um he's
going to be one of the richest men in
America and I know dak's going to take
care of me for the rest of my life
because I'm supporting him so thank you
Dak uh it's a early thank you uh I'm G
let you adopt me since you're having a
daughter here in March and
congratulations on that too so you can
go ahead and adopt me now so uh uh all
jokes aside but I just saw a trending
topic going around um with Cam Newton's
game management comments a video came
out this week saying Cam Newton uh
saying Brock Peru Tua jarro G and Dak
Prescott were game managers not
Difference Maker difference makers or
game changers he has since clarified
what he meant so let's listen to a
little bit what he followed up
with identifying the difference between
a game manager and a game changer game
manager is not a negative connotation
Ken what do you mean by game manager my
definition of that managing player is a
player who has the ability to make the
right play at the right time protecting
the football at all costs there is times
in my career where I figured this out
sometimes Kim you don't have to take
over a game allow other players to do
that if we're getting personal here
there was times in my career where I did
it and there's times in my career where
I didn't do it when I think about
ultimate Elite game managers pton
Manning Drew Brees Tom Brady Game
Changer and game manager is not
something where I'm saying this person
is not physically capable of making some
great plays I'm not saying that or I am
not saying that they're not good players
there's really only three to potentially
five game changers in the NFL right now
Aaron roders Lamar Jackson Josh Allen
Joe Boro Patrick Mahomes Chris KY I was
listening to what he was having to say
and he used this as an analogy a game
changer is a truck a game manager is a
trailer a truck pulls a team together
and pulls and is the reason why this
team is having success a game manager is
merely a trailer that's attached to
something to make it go when I see a guy
like Brock per yes did he make hell of a
throws yes is he making Elite decisions
yes but he's putting it in guys like
Debo Samuels and Christian M like that's
that's the point when you think about
those teams first thing I think about
with the Cowboys is the defense is Dak
Prescott playing lights ball right now
hell yeah but the first thing I think
about is the light out defense when I
think about the Miami Dolphins it's t
Hill it's not Tua that's not to say was
not having a great season when I think
about the 49ers it's not Brock par this
is Christian mcaffrey debbo Samuels that
unbelievable defensive line Kyle
Shanahan who's calling his ass off with
with just putting the schematics in
place these are guys I with these are
people who I respect being a game
manager is not something that it's a
backhanded compliment a game changer is
this as an organization going into the
allseas season our main pick or our main
emphasis on trying to decide a
quarterback is oh man we got to go find
us another A-Rod the next Patrick
Mahomes Josh Allen Lamar Jackson and
this may make a lot of people feel a
certain type of way but it's the truth I
don't see people going into the draft as
Executives of franchises they don't say
I'm going into the draft to find another
Dak Prescott Brock Pur Jared G two a
Tong of aloa remove you from that source
and does that team still be successful
most of those players that I named there
those teams will still be
successful I mean to be honest cam has a
fair point right and I'm not taking away
from any player any person not even my
quarterback um because honestly Dak is a
Difference Maker I think Dak is
showing his his I think there needs to
be a balance right there's a point in a
game where you have the game under
control and you need to learn how to
manage a game but I've seen at this
point in time where we needed touchdowns
and we didn't get steps where we needed
to be in position uh to win games and
our defense did Step Up it you can't
consistently always be the Difference
Maker right at some point in your time
you have to be a game changer like you
don't always have to to
be a game changer you can personally be
a game there's nothing wrong with having
a good team and I think that's the
problem in football and analysts where
we we we often take so much time
into why a person's having success and
we try to like default them for that
right cuz when Dak didn't have Brandon
Cooks and he didn't have uh mg was still
coming back from his ACL injury it was
Dak didn't have no weapons he didn't
have no one to throw to now that he's
putting the ball into Brandon Cooks CD
Lamb's hands uh mg's getting back in the
picture Jake Ferguson now he's just a
manager it's like you you really can't
choose right it's like we'll defend a
guy if they don't have weapons if they
don't have the offensive line right and
and we' seen that we' seen that at
Burrow the year he went to the Super
Bowl his offensive line wasn't very good
and he had to be a Difference Maker he
had to be a game changer extend plays
right he had to do a lot but he had the
weapons right so we can't always fault
right no no one's ever going to have the
perfect o line the perfect receiver uh
the perfect defense I remember Dak uh
when during his first couple years when
the offense was loaded right and they
had all the weapons but they didn't have
a defense that's really wasn't known for
defense and no one talked about uh was
Dak a game changer or a Difference Maker
it was the cowboys that have defense
they putting up 30 plus points Dak had
over 4,500 4600 yards but people weren't
talking about the Cowboys defense then
you know so I don't think that's a fair
judgment right if I think and and it's
painful it it's painful because we try
to critique what's fine right just let
people play ball it it it turn like I
think people forget at the end of the
day it's about winning right it's about
winning when cam won his MVP he was
winning he had a good defense Cam went
to the Super Bowl he had Luke kley he
had Thomas Davis let's not forget the
defense that cam had at that time the
gear that went to the Super Bowl they
they had that right so what what can we
talk about here I don't think that you
can look for a team and say and and to
be fair right Kansas City wasn't always
uh you know a defensive team they're
starting to become more of a defensive
team now right and we can say Patrick
Mahomes carried a lot of that weight
right but Patrick Mahomes had a a pretty
good offensive line last year you know
you got Creed Humphrey you got Tyler you
got you had Orlando Brown he was a pro
bowler and he did have to make a lot of
throws and a lot of risk but he Kelsey
but he never really had a receiver once
Tyreek Hill left but outside of him who
who else can we really say that right
before you know like I don't want to
critique too many people but it's just
not a fair judgment you're not always
going to have everything right and it's
just not fair at the end of day defense
wins
championships you can't
fault Dak Prescott for having a good
defense
right that that's not realistic you
can't fought doc Brock pie for having a
good defense that's the GM that's John
John Lynch he's the ones putting this
team together he's trading for these
people not Brock py you
know at the end of the day as a
quarterback you need to come and be
prepared you need to help your team win
that's that's that at the end of the day
right football is a team
sport so it doesn't matter if Doc and we
saw this with Jaylen Herz in the Super
Bowl it doesn't matter if you have 400
yards five touchdowns if your defense
does not get a stop you will not win you
C you cannot
win like
it it it's wrong but it's Cam Newton
right in a sense is there tears of
quarterbacks can we say that yes there
are tears of quarterback is anyone on
the same level of Patrick Mahomes in the
last four or five years no
Patrick Mahomes has been an a very elite
quarterback regardless at the end day
Patrick Mahomes has can I say there's
tears we can all agree that there's
tears and quarterbacks that is but
that's not the
discussion I think if there's a chance
for
you to go win a game and you go win a
game that's what you do Dak Prescott
there's a crazy stat he has I think 16
drives where he goes down and win the
game is anyone throwing the ball but him
no D Prescott's doing that at the end of
the day you can't be faulted for having
a good
foundation you can't be
right Dak Prescott's not drafting these
your GM your owners are putting the
teams together you cannot be faulted for
having a you know what I'm saying like
and I think that's a a a lot of times
what we do we
justify people's greatness people's
success
for what they have at the end of the day
who cares
right it's a it's about who has the best
team it's a team sport if Dak doesn't
play very well and we're playing very
well and we pick up the slack for him
the my damn that's how we do it that's
what teamwork is for you won't be able
to tell a weak person if six people are
carrying a couch you can only tell a
weak person if one person trying to
carry the couch or maybe two because
it's starting to tilt right like let's
be realistic here
and and then on the flip side a lot of
people in the media have brought up Cam
Newton's career to discredit his
opinion and this is the part where I
hate right I grew up a Cam Newton fan
I'm all for cam I I was a Panthers fan I
had to cam cleats the under armoured
clam cleat because I wanted to be like
Cam Newton
right we're not going to sit here and
act like Cam Newton is not an MVP right
just because he didn't play as long as
Tom Brady Drew Brees and Kurt Warner and
and a bunch of other greats that played
this game does not discredit Kim
Newton's opinion and cannot act like we
don't know that cam knows the game of
football he played at an MVP level he
was one of the best quarterbacks in the
game at the point in his career before
the shoulder surgeries and all that
other stuff Cam Newton was that guy and
if you watch the full
video he makes a great
Point people often
times
disguise the
truth with criticism right they didn't
go into think what cam meant they
started attacking him
right why are you attacking him if you
rebuttal cam great but why are you
attacking him cam knows more ball than
N9 85% of analysts right if you never
played the game if you never coached it
or been at a high level how would you
ever know what really goes on right
people now right and and this is the
problem with the big bully media where
we always get into it they want you to
just shut up and let them handle it so
they just want you to so they they're
trying to try to bully you out of the
media and they're like they want to tear
a person down that's why I'm like
everyone has a platform to this is a
land of the free like you can speak
whatever you want on any surface you
want whether people like it or not
you're due to your
opinion it is not wrong for what he said
and he corrected himself so let cam say
whatever he want in a category where he
was a lead cam
323822 touchdowns Jaylen Herz and Lamar
is breaking his records but cam was a
guy and and we can't act like that
so let's let's not get into that
right but he's not wrong when you think
cuz at the end Daye when you think about
certain teams you do say hey they do
have this but it's just over criticism
because we don't have nothing else to
talk about you know I do think Tyreek
Hill is a MVP
favorite I think Tyreek Hill can
almost hoop I think Tyreek Hill could go
to any team in the NFL and do what he's
doing
I don't think you have to be uh Patrick
Mahomes or Tu to throw it to Tyreek at
all um you know so there's parts of it
where you can agree and if people took a
personally I you you can say I see why
but in reality he's not wrong but you
shouldn't
fought a guy for having a good team
because
he didn't put it
together so that's kind of like how I
feel about it agreed or disagreed let's
just go in something from last week
we're we're going to get into the
Patrick Mahomes Fiasco the frustrations
um him visibly upset uh Patrick was
visibly upset to Josh Allen um on the
sidelines is Patrick right for being
upset I think absolutely abolutely and
then also you can say absolutely not and
this is kind of why I say it
[Applause]
right Patrick Mahomes can be upset
because it's a football is emotional
it's hard to win up in the game and then
when you when you're about to win in a
fashion they won you hate to see why
they lost
it's okay to feel upset
because how much you put into the game
and you want your team to win
desperately why people may say it's not
okay is because Patrick Mahomes is a
leader he's a franchise quarterback he's
they he shouldn't show emotion you know
the whole Mantra ego that men can't show
emotion is not good for their brand or
whatever you want to say emotion's
perfectly fine I don't think that he
should not be able to show his immersion
could he have toned it down yeah for
sure but this is why I do think it's
okay because if we look at where
cadarius Tony's standing right and and
trust me I get this a lot before they
call me alignment off sides I would get
a warning from my coaches then I'll get
a warning the ref would come up to me
personally and say hey you've been off
sides and if I'm looking at this
correctly
and I I saw something earlier in the
week that there was multiple times where
cadarius Tony was aligned like
this if I'm looking at this correctly I
feel
like you there was no warant like
there's just certain things you don't
call in this space you have to give
warnings like cuz he was aign like this
a couple other times throughout this
game so it's just
the Inc
consistencies
of um of the game I get it the rule is
not wrong he was off
sides but you gotta call it fairly and
you got to give War you don't have I get
it I get it it it I think this is a
tough call either way very tough call uh
but I do
think there's one thing to have the
motion on the sideline um but you just
can't let it carry I don't think he'll
let it carry this week uh Patrick is
obviously a great quarterback and he
does a lot of great things and he's a
great leader so they'll overcome this
but it just is what it is you know
it you can't control everything that
happens in the game there's when you
have reps and umpires they have
controlability too right they control a
part of the game um and that's just is
what it is something else I want to get
into I saw my man Zach Wilson go crazy
um I want to him to get a big shout out
that's what it looks like to play loose
he had nothing to lose and had a career
day couldn't have been more proud of him
uh gave him a big shout out like major
um that was dope to see I hope I
continue to see that Z just keep putting
on the film if you want to be in this
league just keep putting that film on
that you can play great
ball you don't need anyone to believe in
you you just need your loved one
just keep doing what you're doing don't
stop
period at a day you know there's a guy
named Eric Rogers who's gonna come back
um and you know that's G to be their guy
I think everyone's made that public and
whatever but if they decide to move on
from you you want to show these people
something they can remember and that was
your first step and I felt that when I
was watching I was like that is dope to
see very dope
let's get into Chargers historic law
sheesh when I first saw like I would
they said are you going to watch the
game and I said probably not like it's
the charge they both don't have their
quarterbacks like whatever and my friend
text in group chat yeah this game's over
it's 490 half I said what ain't no way I
checked ESPN and said what I I I mean I
couldn't believe
it and then the final score scor
63-21 this was the most points Los
Angeles had allowed in franchise history
and the most lost Vegas has ever scored
Raiders lost last week three- Z to the
Vikings am I surprised Brandon Staley
got
fired probably not considering the that
type of
game I mean th this is
tough I mean do games like this happen
yes like we beat the Vikings bad at home
um I mean we got beat going up to
49ers I mean blowouts happened
like the Vikings came back on the bills
I mean not blowouts but things that
shouldn't happen and I mean people are
talking about he blew a 27-0 lead to the
Jaguars in postseason last year
comebacks happen I mean the coach coach
did get fired when he blew that lead I
mean
that happened but they do happen like
we're just going to act like blowouts
don't happen I mean this is was an
extreme blowout but they happened I mean
didn't the Dolphins blow out the
Broncos like it is the NFL right and
then they put up a they didn't break the
record but it was it wasn't like 72 or
73 points so I'm not going to say he's
wrong and believe it or not I believe
Shawn Payton was the head
coach um
so he's not
wrong blowouts games like this do
happen
um but I think he was already borderline
so a game like that can't happen for you
you know that's kind of like the choosy
choosy
modifications
um and then there was a point in the
game people were saying why are there a
Eckler celebrate offens players
signaling first down when they're losing
right I think this is more just
confidence and especially as a captain
right and you're still in the game down
63 to seven you need to keep boosting
your team and wanting them to play I
don't care where you're
at this is a games like this is how you
could lose the locker
room whether you're losing or winning
you need to have the same energy in the
same commitment to your
team it like I don't think it matters
what the score is you should have energy
it it's just like right you have bench
players or people who don't
play whether the team's winning or
losing do you not expect them to stand
up and boost the team so what does it
matter if you're in a Sil on the field
the energy needs to always be the same
it's called being a good
teammate it's called being a good
teammate period period it doesn't
matter
um it does not matter you need to be a
good teammate the celebrate I don't care
be excited for your teammates be excited
you got a first down you need a it's
called building it's called
growing and obviously my dog Max Krabby
pulled up to the desk shirtless with a
cigar Max has 13 and a half sacks this
year I mean we're really battling out
with these sacks Max is balling he's
having an unbelievable year he's hooping
this is the year he told me he was going
to have and I believed them people
wonder if Bill bellich is parting ways
with the uh Patriots after season as he
going to the Chargers is that a good fit
I believe so I think Justin Herbert
shows his value to this team how much
they need him uh Bill bich knows how to
win close
games bill bich is one of the greatest
coaches and he'll good a quarterback
that cares and shows effort and he'll be
put him him in a great position to win I
think it'll be a great Tandem and they
have great defensive players Bill's
known for his defense I think this would
be great um this is a team who lost in a
margin of three the most team most three
point less than three-point games in the
last three four years I think Bill bich
put some over the top without a doubt
very excited to see this off SE I think
this offseason is gonna be one of the
craziest off Seasons we've seen in a
very long time very long time
let's take some final questions from the
chat before we get into cowboys versus
Bills is Tomy DeVito's agent the most
stylist agent in NFL absolutely not I
think my boy David Muller is the most
styish agent in NFL he's uh he's that
guy you know for sure if you ever see
Dave pop out he gonna pop out uh when
did Max tell you he was having a big
year uh when we were when I was in Vegas
at Von Miller's uh pass rush Summit Camp
M me and Max talked a lot we was going
over over some pass for stuff and uh you
know we were just talking about the
years and what we about to have and you
know everybody was kind of talking a
little bit of trash um max got more
sacks to me right now I got to I got to
I got to step up you know I we
definitely had a little uh little on who
going to have a better year and stuff
like that so uh it's a it's a close race
right now uh it's going to be exciting
to see these last four games what do
advice do you have for Mazy Smith
getting opportunity out to H uh Hank his
out as talking to Mazy last week and uh
and you know as a teammate for me uh
some people it it's
funny cuz DW and all them other people
have a uh have a saying for me and it's
like man sometimes you could just come
off like a a-hole it's like why like I
feel like I'm one of the nicest
people and uh it's the
way that someone says
something to you and sometimes right I'm
emotional how I like to get things done
um but I tell
you what you need to hear not what you
want to hear and sometimes people don't
like that and uh and Mazi was like man
tell me what I need to do I want to be
great bro and one thing I told Mazy I
was like bro you gotta come in here with
intent every day to get
better um you gotta have
you got to have that unbelievable amount
of faith in yourself that we haven't cuz
we need you I was like we I would have
begged for you if I didn't believe you
had the potential of what you could
be um and I and especially as a young
guy and I'm not really familiar with his
position but I told Mazy like we need
you if we want to win this thing we need
Mazy Smith to be his best and uh I think
that's something he took personal I
think this week I think I'm excited to
see how he plays in that big step that
he
makes what's the most difficult part you
think of playing against Josh Allen um
for me I think the most difficult part
is how good Josh is and how good he is
with his legs and extending plays um his
energy contagious I mean Josh is second
to none on uh the type of player he is
it's going to be a very exciting
matchup last of people want to know
about the weather in Buffalo are you
worried about playing Buffalo 49 degre
in rainning
do people don't understand I'm from Penn
State I'm from up North I am very well
used to this type of weather Penn State
weather used to be atrocious
atrocious like it was no fun but we're
used to it I'm from Penn State baby like
we're used to
this but we're getting into Bills
Cowboys bills bills are coming off a big
one in Kansas City fighting for a
playoff spot not currently in the play
play offs with a 7-6 record Josh Josh
Allen leads the NFL total touchdown and
Doc Prescott leads the NFL passing
touchdowns I'm just looking for two
great quarterbacks to battle out I know
they're going to come down it's going to
come down to the wire I think it's going
to be a very exciting game especially
with the weather conditions who can
overcome the adversity who's going to be
able to drive down and make the big
plays at the big plays and at the right
time it's gonna be very exciting um
whose idea was it to put pctures on a
pictures of Builds on equipment trust me
it wasn't my idea this is all offense uh
defense we kind of just talk about the
ball and it's shark week for us and
things like that but you know this is
their own thing the offense guys
decideed to
do uh J Bill's offensive coordinator Joe
Brady said made a comment about me this
week and he
said he said he decided when he wanted
he wanted to play wide receiver for the
camp he was the best wide receiver in
the camp everything he's doing in the
NFL doesn't surprise me at all an
absolute freaking athlete well Joe Brady
I am playing wide receiver this week and
I want your best corner that's how I
feel about it and that's the truth I
might be the best wide receiver that no
one's ever seen no one's ever seen trust
I'm coming I'm playing wide receiver
next week 11 and
888 11 and 88 and three about to take
this thing over man simple I'm coming
out back out of retirement I see y'all
Sunday I'll be lined up as wide receiver
the catch at the bag now take that for
bait or whatever y'all want to say thank
y'all for tuning in to the podcast I see
y'all on Sunday I'm going to get a
touchdown baby
[Music]
simple